et pourquoi pas découvrir et soudain
sous un autre angle à bord d'un canoë
cette famille s'est laissé séduire par
cette proposition de balade plutôt
insolite et dépaysante dans la cité
berrichonne monsieur se chargent de
pagayer et madame danielle d'habitude
c'est ma femme qui fait tout alors
exceptionnellement jeu payet sait pas ce
que c'est les vacances
exactement il faut pas que ces sommes il
faut pas qu'elle s'habitue au pénal à
s'imaginer où on est d'ailleurs nous qui
sommes dit soudain en a on n'arrive pas
à se situer de savoir de quel côté on
est d'issoudun mais quel jardin maison
une rivière méconnu la théols serpente
entre les parcs et les jardins privés
elle permet d'avoir un autre point de
vue sur les monuments comme la mairie et
la célèbre tour blanche on voit la tour
blanche qu'on peut visiter tout l'après
midi est également quelquefois en
nocturne ont fait des faits la nocturne
canoë la nocturne avec la tour blanche
et on voit également le beffroi le
beffroi c'était la porte de la ville à
l'époque c'est là où se mêlent alerte
quand il y avait quelqu'un qui arrivait
qu avait des mauvaises intentions
lorsque sébastien tardy a eu l'idée
d'exploiter cette rivière personne ne
l'a prise au sérieux mais avec 30
centimètres à deux mètres par endroits
le cours d'eau est resté navigables
toute la saison on peut aussi passer
sous le musée de l'hospice saint roch
avec quelques précautions tout de même
ne vous pensez pas ne vous penchez passe
à l'extérieur voilà allez c'est à
monsieur
eh bien monsieur décalé sur la gauche
décalé sur votre gauche à issoudun les
balades en canoë se poursuivront
jusqu'en septembre histoire de terminer
l'été en beauté